hello everybody and welcome to a
tutorial series for programming for
Finance in this series we're gonna be
talking about how we can leverage
programming to help us in the field of
Finance so a lot of people you're
programming with finance and they
immediately think of high-frequency
trading well programming with finance
while it can help us with high-frequency
trading it can help us all the way down
from you know high-frequency trading to
long term investing so when people think
of high-frequency trading the reason why
they think of that is because the
machine can calculate and make positions
and execute trades faster than a human
even can possibly do it okay but
actually with long term investing we can
use programming there as well because in
the research process
a good example of this would be one of
the series we did on this channel not
too long ago using machine learning
going over the fundamental aspects of
companies things like price-to-book
ratio and stuff like this going over
those numbers and going over them over
the past yes a decade and training a
classifier with machine learning to
classify a company is either likely to
continue producing good numbers or not
now to do this by hand would probably
take someone to go through the entire
S&P 500 and to go like save month by
month on all the fundamental data and do
all the linear algebra required that
would probably take them about 10 years
so by the time they even figured out
what's a good company to invest in is
too late so we use machines for this
also machines just come with less bias
humans love patterns you know it's
arguable that one of the reasons why
we've evolved so well is our extreme
ability to recognize patterns but this
is actually kind of one of the flaws of
us because we're we just see patterns
and everything even when patterns aren't
there so anyways with with programming
and finance one of the biggest things
that we can do is test our ideas and/or
train our ideas or find new ones and do
research okay and also like risk
analysis on any strategy we might we
might try to employ so with programming
there's obviously a massive barrier to
entry and then with finance there's a
massive barrier to entry and using
programming with
finance that's another barrier to entry
there's all new principals and modules
because we're going to be using the
Python programming language so there's a
whole bunch of barriers to entry here
and then just getting data for finance
right if you want something better than
let's say one-day prices well you got to
find a source and you usually have to
pay for it right so all these barriers
to entry make it really difficult for
somebody to just to get into the field
so what we're going to be doing is we're
going to use Python Python is a pretty
pretty new friendly programming language
as far as new friendly programming
languages go we'll be using Python and
we're also going to be using quanto
peein so quanto peein is a web-based
application where we can go and there's
a built in Python editor there so
basically the text editor where we write
Python code and we can go there write
our Python code and it comes with a all
of the finance modules that we would
want now there might be a few that it
doesn't have as you as you go down the
road but luckily after learning on
quanto peein will make it extremely
simple because for example even if
you're not familiar with Python what I'm
about to say will probably confuse you
so in order to do Python for Finance
you'll need to get Python and you'll
probably have to you can choose 64-bit
and you can because you might want more
than two gigs of RAM but you'll be
better off if you choose 32-bit so you
can download all the modules easily like
numpy for numbers and all this stuff and
then you've got matplotlib then we're
going to need to get a zip line and
unfortunately zip line is only good for
32-bit windows but it's also a pain to
install and you need a bunch of other
stuff and you're going to have to get
for sure pi TZ import PI TZ and you're
going to understand how to convert date
stamps and all this and you're going to
definitely need pandas ok so there's
just a ton of stuff that you're going to
need well we're going to use quanto peon
because quanto peon is going to first of
all already have that stuff for us but
also it's going to do some stuff in the
backend for us that we don't have to
worry about it so one of the things that
they're going to do is for back testing
they have this nice user interface and I
won't talk too much about it so I'll
just show it in a moment so it just
makes sense if
this is your first time into programming
or finance that we go ahead and use
quanto peon
now quanto peon is there's really
nothing I mean they're their websites
probably proprietary but the code that
runs really runs Quon so pian is Python
which is open source and free zip line
again open source free and a bunch of
other Python modules that again are open
source and free so just because you
learn on quanto peon doesn't mean at any
point you can't walk away from quanto
peon so if you have some sort of crazy
algorithm that you you're just too
scared to have on quanto peon
you can leave quanto peon okay so anyway
and also canto pian there's no referral
here they're not paying me to do this I
was just trying to think of the easiest
way to get people into Python in finance
and this has got to be the easiest way
so anyway so head to quanto pian comm
this is their website if you don't
already have an account you'll need to
go ahead and sign up and create an
account once you have done that go ahead
and click on login here and i've already
got an account so i'm just going to go
ahead and login nobody look at me as i
type in my password and when you log in
this is what you'll be seeing so head
over to algorithms we're just gonna kind
of zoom through this feel free to poke
around the website in a moment i just
want to show you what quant opions doing
here for us know the real crux of quanto
pian so you head over here click on
clone sap sample algorithms so this will
give us some some basic algorithms that
quant opions kind of pre-written for us
and we want to look at this sample
algorithm for a basic strategy so just
click on that and up pops over here on
the left is python code on the right
this will be like your returns and stuff
and then down here is like the log this
is like your console from from python if
you're familiar if you're not familiar
that's totally okay we'll take this
pretty slow as we go through Python and
Finance and all the code that we write
so even if you're not familiar with
either python specifically or even
programming hopefully it'll be slow
enough to either you can still follow
along and what i'll end up doing is I'll
end up annotating links to for more
formation on programming topics there
will be tutorials so if you're not
familiar with something just ask a
question or check out the annotations so
over here is Python code and the way
this works is you've got these they look
a lot like functions but they're not
these are methods if you don't know what
that means don't worry about it but
basically you define the method here and
you'll you'll really never need to
define them they're going to come
predefined every time and then under
initialize you write code you know block
a code that runs once and then under
handle data this is the block of code
that runs you know in every iteration
again if you're not totally following
that's absolutely fine it will end up
building our own algorithm from scratch
so you can understand so if you don't
understand what's happening here totally
fine
so anyway what we can do is we can
either build the algorithm here and it
pops up over here or you can just run a
fullback test and you can run it against
daily data or minute data and quanto
peon has that data for you already you
don't have to worry about pulling it and
pre-processing it and worrying about
dates and all this madness and pandas
you won't even have to touch it really
so awesome and so what's going to do is
we're going to take we're going to be
dealing with the security of a APL which
is for Apple which makes expensive
phones and then we have handled data and
under handled data you can see the
algorithm that we're going to be running
so I'm trying to get my zoom just right
uh-huh so everybody can see it nicely
and under here we're generating the
value for the average price which is a
moving average of five days or five
windows and we're using daily data and
then we get the price and then we come
down to the true crux of the algorithm
which is right here and basically it's
just asking if the current price is
greater than the average price and we
have the cash for to pay for the current
price so if we have more cash if the
cash is greater than current price then
we buy the shares else or else if again
if you're not familiar with if and
l-lift statements when we hit them all
annotate through specific tutorials but
they pretty much make logical sense or
at least grammatical sense of you you
know else if current price is less than
the
Brij price what do we want to do so
that's kind of what's nice about Python
it just makes sense if you read it and
then here's some record and we'll talk
about that too but anyways here's the
full crux of quanto peon you hit run
back test and a bunch of code that you
never wrote is running right now and you
can see the results of your training
strategy pop up here it'll take a moment
for it to start but here it goes and so
here you can see this blue line here
this is our algorithm how is our
algorithm doing and then this red line
is the benchmark and the benchmark is
the spy the Spy is the spider sp500
ETF so this basically it follows the S&P
500 and then here custom data this this
is just stock price for now but we'll be
talking about how you can put whatever
you want here and you've got a bunch of
other information here but then here you
can see basically the performance you
know the you know the bottom line of our
strategy is we did good now we'd be we
beat the market because we were trading
Apple okay so don't worry that that
strategy is not uh not some sort of
golden strategy by any means but anyway
we've maybe we beat the market and then
with quant opium not only do we have
this graph but we have this graph custom
data we've got weekly return graph we've
got transactions but that's not all we
come over here we have a ton of stuff
all this stuff here on the left hand
side is incredible this would take us a
really long time to code it quanto
beings already done it you have
transaction details this is all the
moves that we've made log output if you
you know storing things to log and
you've got risk metrics returns Treasury
returns benchmark you've got alpha beta
Sharpe you don't know any of these are
that's okay we'll talk about them as we
get to them but anyway yeah you've got
all this stuff and also drawdown that's
nice that you would want to have in your
research and you'd have to code this and
it would take a very long time but know
what quant opions doing for us and
really what zip line is the module with
what Squanto peon and zip line is doing
for us is basically taking out all the
necessary coding to the statistics of a
strategy and it allows us to just create
the strategy and then get all the
information we want out of it so it's
extremely useful now that's it for now
in the next video we'll actually will
talk about creating our
own algorithm and you know what goes
into that and so we'll kind of break
down that other that page that we're
just looking at we can go back to sample
algorithm here we'll go back into
basically what we know what goes into
the creation of an algorithm here and so
we'll create our own algorithm we'll
just do a simple one so we'll be talking
about that but that's quanto peon if you
have questions or comments up to this
point feel free to ask if anything is
confusing or you don't know what's
happening here I have a ton of tutorials
that you can follow along with so let me
head over to Python programming net and
so this is Python program that has my
tutorials website you can always come to
start learning and if there's a concept
you don't understand you can always come
to the search bar and type in whatever
it is you're looking for so let's say
it's if statements you could type in if
if statement and there you go there's a
tutorial on that if you need to just run
through the basics these are the basics
and that's that also if you're
interested in that and like the machine
learning stuff that's here data analysis
machine learning then here is that
fundamental investing tutorial series I
was talking about so anyways that's that
like I said I'll try to annotate to
anything that I think a newcomer
wouldn't necessarily know right out of
the gate but I'm going to miss a lot
there's a lot of information that'll be
thrown at you if you're not familiar
with Python or even programming at all
so anyways that's that questions or
comments leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching things for
all the support and subscriptions and
until the next video if you have
annotations turned on you'll be able to
click on the videos at the end of every
tutorial to move on to the next part
also if you have annotations on I will
be annotating various things that you
can click for references so if I
reference kind of a new programming
topic I'll annotate to a tutorial on it
also maybe some finance principles if
you're not familiar
I'll have annotations to those as well
so if you need a little bit more
information you'll be able to click on
the annotations to learn more so if you
don't have annotations turned on you can
turn them on by going to the gear at the
bottom right of the YouTube video go
ahead and
click on that that's for your settings
and there's an annotations option just
turn that on a lot of people use and
abuse annotations for like advertising
and stuff like that so if you turn them
on just you might want to turn them off
at the end but I promise I won't be
abusing them for advertising or anything
like that so that's all